what's up everybody how are things with
you hope everything's fine whatever you
are
this is spanish grandmaster peppa quinca
and it is an enormous pleasure to be
here with all of you
uh to talk about one series that has
been
a revolution in the chess wall and also
outside the chest well
yes i'm talking about the queen's gambit
a new
netflix production and i have to tell
you that i have just finished
this series two days ago and i found it
extremely interesting i really enjoyed
from the first episode to the last one i
think the photography is very nice
the main actress does a fantastic job
and
in my opinion it's the best chess
production that i have seen
in the last years so what am i doing
here today well
we're not talking about uh cinema or the
cinema industry i don't have any future
about
as a film critic or a cinema critic but
of course we are talking about chess
and there were so many people asking us
if we can analyze the games that appear
in the show so that's why we're gonna
cover four or five games that appears
in the show and we're starting from the
first episode so
we are not gonna make any spoilers so
don't worry about this
so we are just focusing on chess but
anyway i recommend you to watch the
series and then come back here
so we just talk about the chess and then
about the people who play those games
so the first game we covered happened in
the first episode
and beth harmon the main character was
facing mr guns
who is a a a guy from the chess club who
wants to see how she plays so that's why
he visits her
and then they play a game so let's
just focus on chess and beth harmon
decide to go
for e4 then mr ganza replies with
c6 the karokan defense one of the most
solid approaches nowadays so d4
occupying the center
d5 from mr guns so here there are
different ways to play
yes i forgot to tell you so this game
actually is based
in a real game but we we're gonna talk
about the real
players after showing you this game so
you can guess who were the players
after seeing this game alright so knight
c3 here
as i told you different options you can
go for the advanced variation with e5
also knight d2 also et xd5 and then
f3 for those who are a very aggressive
players i recommend you to go for this
line you want to continue with knight c3
bishop e3 queen d2 and then long castle
and then
go crazy attacking your pawn skin but
okay knight c3 main line
d takes e4 from mr guns and now knight
takes e4
and here mr guns decides to go for not
f6
the main move is bishop f5 and then
main move is knight g3 also knight c5 is
very interesting i recommend you to take
a look
but knight g3 attacking this bishop is
the main line bishop g6
here even though you can go knight a3
and knight f4 for example the main
line is h4 trying to trap this bishop so
that's why black plays
h6 and then normally white continues
with h5
fixing the structure bishop h7 and then
bishop d3
in order to trade this fantastic bishop
on h7
bishop d3 queen takes e3 not f6
another three and here in many cases we
reach
uh positions where both kings are
castled in
opposite flanks so that's why you get so
many interesting
games and positions but this is heavy
theory yeah i mean in order to
understand everything that's going on in
this position we will need
hours probably days or weeks or months
so just to give you an idea about the
main line
but mr guns decides to go for not f6
which is also
a very interesting move even the best
chess players in the world
have tried this idea now white takes
sorry white goes for queen d3 main line
is knight f6 and then here you are
forcing
black to ring his pawn structure
actually both moves are interesting you
can take with the g
pawn and then you get really unbalanced
positions black has ruined
his pawn structure also the game is
going to be weak on the king side but in
return actually
you get more control in the center and
also the g file is opened
for this rook more normal is probably
etx f6 and then again you got double
points on the f5 but now you just
developed this bishop in one tempo
and black is able to castle very soon so
that's why this position is very
interesting
you can also try queen e2 not in this
position because
the pawn falls but then maybe in a
bullet game just to see your opponent
goes for knight bd7 and then boom
checkmate on d6 yeah forget about that
yeah let's not be so lazy
so beth harmon decides to go for queen
d3
just covering this uh knight on e4 and
here there are
different interesting moves for example
you can play g6 knight takes e4
all of them are playable and also the
move that mr guns
plays which is e5 attacking the center
and then asking why what he wants to do
she wants to do because if now
white takes on e5 then mr grant's idea
is to go for
queen a5 check followed by
queen takes e5 and then pinning this
knight on e4
so that's why this is a really uh
interesting and important moment for
white in this position what would you
play with the white pieces
i would like you to to stop this video
and then think about this position
of course there are many playable move
moves sorry for example knight f3 but
then i think black just takes on d4
and then you cannot take on d4 because
actually the
the knight on e4 is just hanging and
after something like knight f6
queen f6 queen d4 will reach some sort
of equal position right after bishop b7
or even queen takes c4
everything is very symmetrical and i
think black is fine in this position
so that's why beth harmon said you know
what
mr guns i'm just gonna take this pawn on
e5
and now black actually went for a queen
eight five the most natural move i mean
if you'll trade queens from d3
this is just good for for white right
because after knight takes e4
bishop takes e4 white is a healthy pawn
up and you know black has
not in enough compensation for the
sacrifice pawn
so that's why mr guns goes for queen eve
a5 sorry
bishop d2 just blocking and now queen
takes e5
and now asking why what she wants to do
with this knight on e4 because there is
a nasty pin
on the e file and this is probably one
of the most important
moments of this game i recommend you to
pause the video for a while
so this way uh you get a rest uh from my
face right
and now it can be a little bit tiring at
least this is what my mom says all the
time
and uh just trying to think about the
position
so i'm sure that many of you have
thought about this move
f3 which is a humble move but probably
effective just protecting the knight on
e4
but i think black is just fine after
knight takes e4 if you take with the
queen
after the queen trade i think black is
even better because the structure is
much better for black
black has two islands and white has
three islands
so there's no reason to think that white
is better in this position
so if you take with the pawn yeah
it is interesting but now black takes on
b2 and i think tasty not
there's not enough compensation for the
sacrifice pawn
so that's why f3 is not the best move in
the position then what to play
uh this knight is just falling right so
the best move and this is what
beth harmon did it's just long castle
and then again probably
many of you at home will be saying come
on stupid spanish guy
what a bad move long castle you know you
just blundered your knight on e4
well it's not that simple because now if
black takes
with a queen on e4 it's clear that after
rookie one the queen is pin
and actually white is winning the best
move in this position
was just bishop e7 and i think after
knight f6
queen f6 not a3 white is a little bit
better we are
leading in development and then we have
some annoying moves like bishop g5
next and i think white is actually a
little bit better
but uh mr guns that was hungry that day
says you know what i'm just gonna take
this knight on e4
and then again i recommend you to pause
the video and then trying to think about
the best move
right now probably many of you have
thought about the move rookie one
saying come on pepe there is an aster
pin on the e file the king and the queen
are on the e file so i'm just going to
take on e4 and something bad it's going
to happen for black in this position
well not that easy because after bishop
f5 black develops another piece protects
e4
and it's true that after f3 white is
gaining a piece but you're actually
closing
the e5 for example after 97 you are
forced to take with the pawn on e4
and now bishop e6 and even though this
position is interesting
it's not winning for white at all and
after queen c5
black has managed to survive in this
position right
so rookie one not the first not the best
move again
i have been insisting enforcing moves
for six years already in chess 24 mainly
in the spanish section
so now i'm gonna insist a little bit in
the english channel too
forcing moves captures checks and
threads
this way you will solve a lot of puzzles
even though at the first glance
you will think like okay this check is
completely ridiculous then you will
realize
that in is actually the winning move
this is the case in this position
what are the checks right now well queen
d7 which which is stupid because black
can just take with the knight or the
bishop
and not queen d8 which is not stupid and
actually it's just winning
black is forced to take on d8 and now we
have so many
checks in this position right jazz
bishop b3 bishop f4
just uh well taking the queen back but
then
black plays queen d5 and wins and you
have
what we call double checks right with
the moves bishop
a5 double check with the rook and bishop
and bishop g5
double check with the rook ambition so
let's first analyze bishop of a5
now black can just play kini 8 and after
rook d8 which is another forcing move
kinscapes by e7 but it's not the same if
we play
bishop g5 double check right because now
i mean there is no piece able to protect
uh from both
checks right so not the bishop not the
knight we will need something like a
rhino
to protect both squares but rhino is not
a chess piece at least nowadays right
so that's why black black skin is forced
to move and then
there are only two squares available the
first one is rook e8
and actually after rook d8 is actually
checkmate
and the second one is just king c7 and
this is the way the game continued and
now
beth harmon just played bishop d8 and
this is a checkmate this is the first
ra that she did in the series now
the default is completely covered also
this b6 square it's a fantastic game
from beth harmon
and actually we're going to tell you
that this game corresponds
to retti versus tartar cover
from 1910 so we all know already we all
know tartakov well ready
uh we owe him the ratio opening right
one of my favorite openings
with 93 and uh you know he was also a
great
composer you can check actually some
artistic end games
from reddit you're going to enjoy them a
lot so i hope you guys enjoyed
this uh this game and as i told you we
will be covering the next games that
appear
in the show so it's been a pleasure as
usual i hope you guys
enjoyed as much as i did analyzing this
game for you so just
have a nice day take care and stay
healthy bye bye guys